when you talk about like changing your
physical appearance so like when you
played mysterio on the spider-man movie
you decided to grow the beard but you
have to go in front of the whole marvel
universe and say do you think it's cool
if mysterio wears a beard you're not
allowed to just make that decision on
your own right well beard length was
definitely an issue for that one i
didn't have a lot of control over the
length of the beard the beard was
already something they desired so oh i
think so i mean look i got there and
there were you know there's that first
day before you start and everyone is
like longer shorter well if we go
shorter
we can't we're going to have to commit
to this you know um
i mean it's absurd but um
but there was an ease there's an ease in
those movies even though they're all
that pressure there's a little bit of
ease you know where they're like
all right you know
beard's not as nice as chris evans but
you know it'll do
for career it's great
to be a marvel superhero means you get
exposed to a whole wide audience that
you normally wouldn't even get exposed
to but a lot of it seems like it's green
screen time it's a lot of physicality
and all this kind of stuff and i i
somehow imagine that you're like [ __ ]
this isn't challenging to me you know
what am i doing here it's hard man that
acting is hard
i mean it's
it's
physically i mean i mean all of it i
mean that world is enormous right in a
situation that was just like
so
a train that was already moving so like
you know for me normally i come in way
early on you know and and i and i get to
play and i get like i get to figure it
out it was like you got to deliver in
that space and and it was a whole
different craft right like
they they're moving with ideas which is
so fun about it it's actually what are
you being creative what do you mean
moving with ideas i mean there's someone
creating the
no i mean they have a structure for the
movie but like if someone has a good
idea if you bring a better idea i mean
they will change and entire they will
shift an entire day around that idea so
it's really creative i mean there was a
first day the first day of shooting
i remember um
not being able to memorize remember my
line like i literally was like you come
to me on this yeah i was like
what the and i was i was i was the
wooden board right and they were like
whoa and i went up to tom hall and i was
like dude help me out he's like it's all
good just relax it's like he was me in
so many situations and i i finally did
but i think i just put a lot of pressure
because i love that world man like it's
not me coming in as an actor going like
oh like i've made i've made
60 films like i know what i'm doing it's
me coming in every time being like
i love spider-man i love this world like
i want to kill it here it's too much
pressure because you're right you're
coming into a juggernaut exactly that's
the pressure that marvel is just too
goddamn good at this yeah exactly like
sam jackson's just rolling with it
throwing out improv they're changing
movies around him and i'm just like i
can't even barely get my line out yeah
they're like this is mysterio get this
[ __ ] guy off the set i mean you're a
guy who does broadway plays you remember
lines i mean i had to i had to walk up
and be like look man i just came off
broadway doing like a one-man show for
an hour and a half on stage like i got
this please just believe me you know